hi i'm schlotzvasa second-year phd
student in computational neuroscience
and i'm almost at the halfway point of
my phd so i thought this would be a
perfect time to kind of give you guys
some tips that i wish i had when i
started my phd and hopefully they will
help you a lot so i will give you some
insight into how to do research better
how to schedule this better how to keep
your energy levels up and also how to
keep motivated for your phd so hopefully
you will learn a lot and let's get
straight into it so the first thing i
would really recommend you getting if
you are just starting your phd or even
if you are already a little bit further
in your phd is to get this id bank so
this is kind of a dedicated place on
your laptop or even a booklet where you
write down all the ideas you have
throughout the year and i made a notion
page for this so i will put it up now so
on my notion page i have for every idea
that i had throughout the year i make a
dedicated page and on that page i
usually put some thoughts or some
queries that i had when i was thinking
of this idea because what you will start
to notice with your phd is that usually
you will have one main project that is
the project that you focus on and that
you dedicate your time towards but
throughout the year you usually get a
lot of new ideas for example if you go
to a conference and you talk to a really
interesting professor they usually give
you some tips or some tricks to elevate
your idea to the next level or they give
you some advice on a new idea that you
could start or a new project
and the thing i noticed is if you don't
have a dedicated place that you put your
projects in or your ideas in that they
kind of get lost over time and you kind
of forget them and then usually when the
point comes that you finished part of
your main project or if you see that
your main project is actually not
working out it's sometimes really hard
to come on the spot up with a new idea
so that's why i would really recommend
to have this a dedicated place where you
put all your ideas and i kind of want to
take you through how i schedule it or
how i put it in my
bank or notion page so as you see in my
notion page i have these different
sections of the phd that i found
important and then in the thesis
planning section i have this dedicated
page where i put for example bayesian
networks extreme value theory brain
aging and different methods and for
example under extreme value theory which
is something i'm working on now we can
then see that i put all the thoughts
that i had throughout the year for this
project and usually i deep dive into
some smaller themes or projects from
this
extreme value theory during that time
and by having these blocks and different
parts of my
project all in one page this really for
me inspires me and allows me to generate
a lot of ideas so usually i'm working on
one main project throughout the year but
i also have a lot of side projects that
i'm kind of simultaneously working on a
little bit throughout the year as well
and the second tip i want to give you
that i wish someone told me at the
beginning is to say no more often so
during your phd there will be so many
amazing opportunities you can do
teaching you can go to conferences you
can help professors with their coding
projects and maybe get your name on
their paper for example and all of these
projects are usually really interesting
and super valuable but the one thing you
don't have endless amount of is time and
i started to notice quite quickly in my
phd that i said yes a lot but then in
the end i didn't have any time left for
my own project and in the end the main
purpose of your phd is to finish your
own projects and your own coding work so
if you don't have time to do this there
is something that you will have to say
no towards and that could be that you do
a little bit less teaching or you don't
go to all the lectures for example and
it will be quite hard into beginning to
really see what you find important and
what you don't find important but as a
general rule i now usually ask myself
this one question to see if i really
want to do this thing or not and that's
just does this thing give me energy yes
or no and if it gives me energy and i
really enjoy doing it i usually say yes
and if it depletes my energy and i don't
really enjoy doing it then i usually say
no and of course there are some things
that you have to do in your phd some
administrative work that no one enjoys
but in general this question really
allows me to say yes and no to the right
things for me and kind of following on
that note for tip three i want to say to
you to keep in mind what you want to do
after because i think once you have a
really clear goal or you're quite sure
of what you want to do after it's a
little bit easier to navigate what you
want to do in your phd so for example if
you know already that you want to go to
a company afterwards it's maybe good
during your phd to already focus on
projects where you can really show your
coding skills whereas for example if you
know already that you want to go on a
10-year track and try to become a
professor maybe it's good to get a
little bit more teaching experience in
at the beginning and kind of thinking
about what you want to do after really
allows you to say yes and no to the
right things in your phd and i've also
seen that people that are a little bit
more clear what they want to do after
tend to stress less actually during
their phd because once you know what you
have to say yes towards there's so many
things that you can just kind of put to
the sidelines and ignore during your phd
so the third thing i want to recommend
you really to do is to take care of your
health and your relationships so a phd
is a really long time in the netherlands
it takes about four years to complete
your phd so if during your student years
you kind of got in this habit of really
cramming and procrastinating i think
during your phd that's really a habit
you need to let go of
because if you don't value your health
and your relationships in four years
they will all be gone basically
and it just helps you so much if you
have a solid foundation in your
relationships and in your health to
actually get better at doing your phd
work and doing your science work so if
you have the tendency and i personally
have this tendency when you're really
stressed to put your relationships to
the side and kind of ignore your health
i think it's good to just block in
really strict schedules of working out
for example or seeing your friends or
having downtime during certain weekends
for example and this helped me at least
tremendously to keep focusing on the
things that are really important because
even though science and your phd is
really important and really valuable i
also think relationships and your health
make up a really big part of your life
as well so my last advice and that
helped me maybe the most i think is to
have another projects beside your phd
something that you can focus on and put
all your creativity towards so for me
that project is youtube right now but
there are a lot of projects that you can
think of starting that will really help
you
create i think another focus point in
your life that you can put your
attention towards so for example you
could think of starting a blog learning
how to program doing youtube or maybe
even picking up a musical instrument and
i would personally pick something
creative because i think having
something really creative in your life
as well sparks joy and energy but also
in the sense that having something
beside your phd that you can learn from
i've noticed that usually this kind of
circles back into your phd so for
example in my phd i now got asked for my
ta job to also help with a little bit of
editing and a little bit of outreach and
i really noticed that i learned these
skills through youtube but now i can
actually use them again in my phd and
that makes me just feel really good and
really valuable so even if for example
you think that music won't help you in
your phd i guess you will be surprised
when you really start deep diving into
another project how much this tunnels
back and what i've also seen is that if
you then get stuck for example in your
phd on a certain project you can work on
your other project that you find really
important and this kind of gives you a
balance in life then instead of putting
all your eggs in one basket which is
your phd you have something else that
you are also cultivating and getting
really good at because for me one of the
most important things of your phd is
that it's the one moment that you can
learn anything you want you dedicated
four years of your life to learning
creativity and wisdom and i think you
should really grasp this chance if you
can so thank you for listening these
were all the tips i had for first years
and if you're starting your phd i'm
really curious
what the topic will be so put it down in
the comments below and also if you're
thinking of starting a phd and you have
any questions please tell me and also
put it down in the comments below and
otherwise see you next week bye